the scp foundation has encountered its
fair share of incredibly tough
adversaries and fearsome monsters but
none are as formidable or at least as
durable as
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
we've talked about this behemoth before
in a number of mind-boggling videos and
all of the increasingly desperate
lengths the foundation has gone to in
order to terminate it we've gotten so
desperate to put this thing to a rest
that we've even reached out to all of
you for suggestions on the matter sadly
they've thrown 682 together with some of
the most destructive anomalies in
foundation custody and it's slithered
out of seemingly inescapable danger
every time so much so that we've noticed
certain researchers on the 682 case have
started drinking a little more heavily
as of late sometimes the threats didn't
leave so much as a dent in the monster's
scales sometimes the other creatures ran
screaming at the sight of it and
sometimes 682 mutated and twisted its
form in ways that were shocking even to
a foundation research team that's seen
just about all there is to see
after all 682's truly insane
adaptability has always been its number
one power and the key to its infuriating
death-defying abilities and these are
some of
scp-682's craziest mutations during one
round of tests
scp-682 was released into an enclosure
with scp-272
a nail that traps any living thing in
place when it is dropped onto the
organism's shadow 682 was surrounded by
32 000 watts stadium lights one of which
was switched on as soon as it entered
the enclosure a d-class dropped the nail
onto the creature's shadow it was
promptly pinned in place and all 30
lights were switched on and off in
random patterns causing the reptile to
be hurled around the room at devastating
speeds after nearly an hour of this
about 95 of the monster skin had been
worn down 63 of its teeth had been
broken from its jaw and its eyeballs had
come loose from their sockets at this
point something truly bizarre happened
the exposed tissue beneath 682's top
layer of skin previously bloody and dark
red began to give off a bright white
light the subdermal tissue grew steadily
brighter and brighter until it eclipsed
the glow from the stadium lights and
removed any shadows cast along the floor
it collapsed on the ground and continued
giving off violently bright light for
the next 48 hours so bright that it
caused permanent retinal damage to all
personnel in the room hell of a light
show but this next mutation proves just
how hard it is to lick as cp 682
especially when it develops the tools to
start licking back
scp-743 is a chocolate fountain that
exhibits some carnivorous qualities when
it is near a living organism especially
if it consumes the fountain's delicious
chocolate it produces swarms of ant-like
monsters that devour the organism piece
by piece carrying the bits into the
fountain until nothing is left the
research team was curious about the
possibilities of introducing 743 to 682
so it was transported to the reptile's
testing chamber within a few minutes
chocolate began to flow from the
fountain 682 was curious and began to
drink from it it may hate almost
everything but even 682 can't resist
chocolate it drank greedily for several
minutes until the foundation began
releasing the ants within moments 682
was covered in ants and in spite of its
best efforts to fight off the swarm it
was completely covered and rendered
immobile the ants made quick work of the
massive creature and after several
minutes it was stripped down to less
than 80 percent of its original mass it
seemed as if this might truly be it for
the beast but then it opened its mouth
it unfurled its tongue now over five
meters long and sticky comparable to an
enlarged version of an anteater's tongue
it began lapping up the ants thousands
at a time picked up by its mutated
tongue as it devoured the ants more
poured out of the fountain slicing off
pieces of 682's flesh with their
pinchers and carrying them back to the
fountain they reached a symbiotic pace
feeding on each other in equal measure
for hours until testing was terminated
that was a sticky situation but trust me
this next crazy mutation will really
blow you away
scp-3108 also known as the nerfing gun
is an altered toy gun that turns
anything it hits into an inferior
version of itself when the gun was fired
at a tissue sample taken from scp-682
the sample turned into a piece of tissue
from a giant leaf-tailed gecko hoping to
carry this over and turn 682 into a
harmless animal a d-class officer was
sent into the containment chamber to
fire the gun at the entity once it was
hit with the foam dart it began to
transform
unfortunately instead of becoming a
simple gecko it began to mutate it grew
larger its muscles bulging noticeably
beneath its scaly skin its teeth grew
longer sharper its tongue sprouting
teeth of its own it opened its mouth to
roar and it appeared that the teeth long
curved fangs with a deadly tip went all
the way back down the beast's throat
security officers were deployed to
temporarily neutralize the monster but
found that it was even more powerful
than before not only was it bigger but
it had developed a new ability when
threatened it would begin to vibrate at
a high rate grinding its teeth together
and would explode in a burst of fire and
meaty chunks fangs flew in every
direction like shrapnel tearing into
personnel and lodging in their skin this
is an impressive move but it seems like
a one-time trick right wrong the bits
and pieces no matter how tiny or how
flattened to mush would crawl back
together and form the creature all over
again it was able to escape containment
like this killing an untold number of
personnel before it was temporarily
incapacitated and returned to its
containment mutating back into life from
a self-induced explosion is pretty crazy
but surely you can't mutate back from
nothing at all right
right
oh boy i don't like that look you're
giving me
scp-3930 is a void located near yusink
russia within which nothing exists once
something has passed within its border
it ceases to be though outside observers
will be able to perceive them for a
small time after
scp-682 was brought into 3930 and it
walked inside once there it ceased
existing however even though 682 no
longer existed foundation personnel
looking at the void could still see the
beast whenever they viewed it a strong
image appeared in the brain of the
person looking and it had the exact
appearance of scp-682
somehow even when it didn't exist 682
was able to attack and kill various
personnel these people did not die from
physical damage but from their brain
function suddenly inexplicably stopping
the reptile defied the rules of the void
somehow causing real destruction even
though it was not real 15 hours later
682 was found in its containment chamber
as if nothing had happened at all it had
been snuffed out of existence and had
mutated its way back into reality with
no explanation well that was
existentially terrifying thank 343 at
least there's only one of those things
oh no
scp-3207 is a highly efficient mobile
war machine outfitted with cannons
capable of firing blasts that can
vaporize organic matter on contact this
seems like a good match for something
supposedly indestructible
3207 was fired at scp-682 several times
appearing to destroy it completely
except for a smudge on the floor of the
chamber the reptile was gone for a
duration of six hours before something
strange began to happen lobster tissue
began to clump together forming five
separate piles they pulled closer and
closer together compressing into five
reptilian creatures they writhed around
getting used to their new legs and teeth
snapping their jaws at any living thing
in sight overwhelming and surprising the
security personnel who had been lulled
into a false sense of security by the
apparent defeat of 682 the five smaller
versions of the entity were able to
escape containment once they had made it
into the hallway
they began to clamber over each other
their scales shifting eyeballs squeezing
together and fusing into one eye skin
stretching like hot rubber over
unnaturally bendy bone as the shocked
security personnel watched the five
lizards melted into one becoming a
full-sized version of scp-682
that was good as new they were able to
contain it after a great deal of effort
but one of the researchers requested a
note to be added to the research notes
for the day and applied going forward do
not explode okay so the big lizard is a
constant threat got it still wouldn't it
be nice if 682 could make itself a
little smaller i can't imagine anything
bad coming from that
scp-1056 is an anomalous kitchen timer
capable of changing the size of living
objects the foundation wanted to see how
long it would take 682 to return to its
original size after being shrunk so they
built a testing chamber connected to
1056's dial and released 682 inside
sealing the door behind it the dial was
set to 0.25 and the activation button
was pressed 682 thrashed around
bellowing as parts of its body expanded
and contracted at random then with no
warning it disappeared d-class personnel
were deployed to investigate the chamber
but it seemed to be completely gone
there was no sign of it it's pretty hard
to lose a giant lizard so naturally they
were all a bit perplexed the chamber was
kept sealed under the assumption that
682 had to still be inside somewhere
sometime later a security officer
spotted 682 outside of site 19 returned
to its original size somehow during the
test 682 used the effects of 1056 to
strengthen its ability to change its own
size it adapted and shrank to a size so
small that no one watching could even
see it anymore and it slipped out
through the sealed door it was even
temporarily able to change the size of
other objects around it shrinking
weapons used to contain down until they
were useless okay so 682 is pretty cool
under pressure but what if we made it a
whole lot colder most of the testing on
682 is done with other anomalies however
sometimes the foundation likes to
simplify it a bit dr carlson suggested
they try something a bit more basic
liquid nitrogen one ton of liquid
nitrogen was poured onto scp-682 from
above as it tends to do the liquid
nitrogen promptly froze the bees solid
they remain stuck in place for about 10
minutes until it began to melt the
frozen cast around it its core body
temperature seemed to skyrocket
producing intense heat that fully thawed
it in three minutes it didn't stop there
though the temperature continued to
increase growing hotter and hotter as if
to deliberately punish the research
staff for even attempting to freeze it
it became so hot that the research staff
had to leave the room an attending
doctor's pen melted the plastic burning
his hands steam rose off the sides of
its body fogging up the windows of the
room the test was abandoned after the
size of the containment chamber began to
melt and they worried the creature would
be able to breach containment once it
was left alone 682 cooled back down to
its usual temperature maybe we should
see what happens if we try a slightly
greener method of destruction 682 was
exposed to scp-166
a young nature spirit that can cause
organic matter in her vicinity to
decompose as soon as 166 was released
into its chamber 682 began to run toward
her even as its body began to melt as it
got closer it began to decay and fall
apart more rapidly pieces of its body
softening and slothing off in chunks by
the time it reached 166 it had melted
down into the shape of a patch of grass
covered with colorful wildflowers 15
minutes later it began to regenerate
itself as it usually does its body
reconstituting at the same rate it was
melting the regeneration process began
to speed up going faster and faster
until it surpassed the rate of melting a
piece of the monster would soften and
flop to the ground but by the time it
landed a patch of regrowth had already
replaced it it eventually beat the
melting process and regenerated to its
original form with one difference it had
a sprinkling of flowers and mushrooms on
its back resembling a forest clearing it
was almost pretty even on top of such a
foul creature until a full-sized tree
suddenly burst out of its back shooting
up to a height of 10 feet and puncturing
the roof of its containment chamber and
i'm afraid that's all we have time for
for one video but this only just
scratches the surface of the weird and
wild mutations we've come to expect from
scp-682 want another video on even more
crazy mutations from the hard to destroy
reptile make your feelings known down in
the comments now go check out how to
kill
scp-682 theories and ideas and
scp-682 waze scp foundation tried to
kill hard to destroy reptile for more
about the foundation's face-offs with
this seemingly indestructible beast